ce que nous avions dit c'est que ça
devait se faire au moment où le réseau
sera complété le réseau va être complété
dans deux ans la pleine indexation va
être en place à ce moment là et je crois
que c'est raisonnable ça stabilise le
financement nous services de garde qu on
a parti québécois qui utilisent la même
vieille recette que le parti libéral
c'est à dire quand on est mal pris on
augmente les tarifs on augmente les
taxes et mme marois avait promis
d'aborder la taxe santé elle profère en
tout cas pour ceux qui gagnent plus de
18 mille dollars par année au lieu de
frapper les jeunes familles et parce
qu'avant les familles à faible revenu
il aurait fallu plutôt se limiter à
annoncer une indexation annuelle c'est
nous la position qu'on préconise et la
leçon de sas etc les jets l'ont toujours
ce genre de conséquences là vous savez
que le gouvernement précédent adopté une
politique d'indexation pour tous les
tarifs gouvernementaux des garderies
avait été laissé de côté nous proposer
oui on propose de toute façon de revenir
à l'indexation pour minimiser le choc
sur les familles alors vous le voyez
s'il demande ce qui fait la manchette
l'augmentation du tarif des garderies
qui étaient gelés je vous le rappelle
depuis sept ans maintenant pour parler
de ce budget qu'est ce qu'on doit en
pensez comment la table est mise pour
cette campagne électorale michel david
concur aux devoirs et luc godbout
fiscaliste professeur en politique
fiscale est inversée de sherbrooke
messieurs bonsoir bonsoir je commence
avec vous luc d'un point de vue
économique
si on se place du point de vue du
contribuable il ya les garderies c'est
un coup à absorber et puis quoi d'eau
riendeau
dans le fond il n'y a pas de changement
la fiscalité il n'y a pas de bonbon avec
des mesures fiscales préférentielles
n'est pas d'augmentation d'impôts de
taxes
il ya effectivement leur ajustement de
la contribution pour les services de
garde à contribution réduite
vous savez dans le fond saler et
augmenter au 1er janvier 2004 ils vont
réglementer en septembre 2014
donc c'est sûr question aux jeunes un
tarif ça fait en sorte par la suite
quand on veut l'augmenter l'augmentation
est plus brutale ça avait été de 5
dollars ça a été de 5 $ jusqu'en
à 2,98 jusqu'à 2004 par le super type
non maintenant on passe à 8 au 1er
septembre on va passer à 9 dollars par
la suite en 2015 et par les autres
envois de l'index et on veut les
élections au revenu disponible
c'est la même indexation que subiront
les droits de scolarité donc services de
garde à contribution réduite et droits
de scolarité augmenteront même rite
annuellement par la suite donc le temps
dégel des tarifs est révolu le tout à
fait mais vous savez si en 2004
lorsqu'on avait fait passer le tarif à 5
à 7 $ la ministre à l'époque monique
jérôme forget avait indexé on serait
rendu à 9 dollars maintenant et les gens
se seraient habitués parce que les
augmentations auraient été annuel c'est
sûr que si on gèle le choc fait toujours
plus mal et c'est ce qu'on vient
d'éviter en disant qu'à partir de 2016
à chaque année on va l'augmenter en
fonction de l'augmentation du revenu
disponible des ménages
michel david qu'est ce que ce budget qui
est mort-né puisqu'il ne sera jamais
voté les rapports de vote quoi que
l'opposition a voté contre
mais qu'est ce que ce budget vient
changer dans le paysage préfectoral
justement la mesure évidemment qui qui
est la plus discutée c'est
l'augmentation des tarifs en garderie il
y aura un prix sans doute à payer mais
du même coup madame marois donne un bel
exemple de la détermination qu'elle
prétend avoir à contrôler les dépenses
ccc lourdement symbolique cette
augmentation la madame marois et la mère
du réseau des cpe et qu'elle décède
aujourd'hui d'augmenter le tarif je
pense qu'il ya un message clair là
dedans maintenant au delà de ça
on sait pas trop ce que ça va donner en
fait dans la vraie vie les la
compression des dépenses qui est
annoncée parce que par exemple quand on
parle donc de limiter à 3% les dépenses
de santé il est clair que ça va faire
mal quelque part je suis convaincu que
pendant la campagne électorale les
partis d'opposition vont s'adonner le
gouvernement pour lui demander il l'a
forcé à se commettre sur l' identité de
façon précise les coupures pas juste
santé derrière dentition de choses mais
je doute qu'on le sache avant la fin de
la campagne pour la campagne sa position
de madame marois très certainement ça
lui ça lui donne de ça donne sa
cohérence à ses prétentions de bien de
bien contrôler dépend le godbout sûr
c'est précisément sur cette question là
plusieurs remettront en question le
réalisme de tout ça on demande au réseau
de la santé de ne croître que de 3%
alors qu'ils me le feront ils le font en
moyenne de presque 5%
deux des dix dernières années parfois
beaucoup plus d'ailleurs est-ce que
c'est réaliste en deux mots mais c'est
sûr que ça va grincer parce que pour
donner 3 % à la santé et augmenter de
manière globale les dépenses du
gouvernement de seulement 2%
ça veut dire que si on enlève la santé
l'éducation l'ensemble des autres
ministères vont voir leur budget de
dépenses diminuer l'année prochaine donc
ce qu'il faut comprendre puisque les
salaires augmentent si le budget global
diminue d autres ministères ça veut dire
des compressions réel et même en santé
pour maintenir la même offre de services
en limitant la croissance à 3%
c'est un groupe extrêmement difficile et
tout ça se fait dans un contexte où on
n'a pas de marge de manoeuvre parce que
on pour retrouver l'équilibré budgétaire
en 15 16
il nous reste encore un demi milliard à
identifier sans aucune réserve pour
prudence de disponible donc le mot serré
et il n'aime pas assez fort le business
marche sur un fil de fer c'est sûr bon
michel guidez nous a plu au cours des
prochains jours
est-ce qu'elle pourrait se dire mais
dans le fond nous partons un peu plus
tôt la semaine prochaine où on s'entend
que ça va être autour du 11 mars
j'ai plutôt l'impression que ça va être
autour du 11 mars je pense quant à mme
marois a intérêt à laisser retomber la
poussière du budget le plus longtemps
possible
il ya aucun bénéfice électoral à tirer
de ce budget là il presque mieux qu'on
l'oublié qu'on a le temps de passer à
autre chose si le début de la campagne
mais on va y revenir
de toute manière c'est incontournable la
question budgétaire mais la madame
marois ayant elle même bien annoncer ses
couleurs
je pense que c'est monsieur monsieur
couillard qui vont être les plus mal
pris monsieur kouyate devra présenter un
cadre budgétaire jusqu'à présent ne sait
rien il nous parle d'un échéancier
variable selon les chiffres qu'il
trouvera si jamais il arrive au pouvoir
on n'a aucune idée de la façon dont il
voudrait atteindre le déficit zéro alors
le fardeau de la preuve je peux dire
retomberez lui dans le code de la cac
on verra le détail la décompression et
des réductions de dépenses publiques
qu'ils entendent faire mais c'est assez
clair eux il entend prendre les moyens
si drastiques soit il pour atteindre le
budget le déficit zéro dès l'an prochain
mais ce client nous annonce en entrevue
pardon tout à l'heure qu'il entendait
déposer rapidement un cadre financier on
verra on verra donc michel david merci
le godbout les grandes esquisse de ce
budget deuxième budget je répète aux
gens qui se droguent qui n'est pas comme
les autres puisqu'il est à peu près mort
né mais il sera représenté
si jamais le gouvernement
parce qu'il est quoi l élu est reporté
au pouvoir messieurs merci beaucoup n'y
a pas de voie au revoir